à ce péage près de dijon des contrôles
de vitesse d'alcoolémie et vérification
des papiers une opération classique en
ce grand week-end de départs en vacances
les gendarmes en profite pour rappeler
quelques règles essentielles
on demande aux gens de bien vérifier la
pression de leurs pneus
tout ce qui est chargement que ce soit
un changement correct pas surcharger au
niveau des véhicules et les enfants
soient bien attachés qu'ils allaient
dispositif adéquat par rapport à leur
âge malgré la prévention
beaucoup trop de comportements à risque
sont encore observées comme cet
automobiliste flashé à 150 km au lieu de
je faisais pas attention à vitesse et
pas du tout je dirais effectivement
concentrer sur la route mais pas sur la
vitesse la vitesse est pourtant la
première cause des accidents mortels
et c'est la principale infraction
constatée lui véhicule ce matin on était
pris à des vitesses supérieures 30 km
heure par rapport à la limitation
on a également deux conduites en ayant
fait usage de produits stupéfiants sous
cannabis pour l'un des deux conducteurs
et ce cannabis et amphétamines pour le
second avec la particularité et la
dangerosité qui conduisait un véhicule
poids lourds même opération de contrôle
un peu plus loin avec la police les
véhicules sont minutieusement inspectée
ben oui là-bas la pac devant vapeur
devant ils ont des petites des petits
macarons et philippe de sas vrai que
c'était usées sur les côtés donc on
vérifie ça directement avec le
conducteur
de son côté le préfet met en garde
contre un phénomène très présent ces
derniers temps celui des conduites
extrêmement dangereuse il ya des
personnes qui se comporte sur la route
comme s'il faisait un rodéo comme s'ils
étaient dans un jeu vidéo qui font
réellement n'importe quoi avec des
changements de file des queues de
poisson des vitesses totalement
déraisonnable y compris en zone urbaine
il faut que nos concitoyens n'hésite pas
à signaler ces comportements d'autres
opérations de contrôle comme celles ci
vont avoir lieu tout au long du week end